turn the mat wall show the Red Wave did
not come to pass but it wasn't a
decisive win for the Democrats either so
how do we interpret this and where do we
go from here we'll talk about that today
also voting machines were having hiccups
in Arizona well hiccup is one way to put
it and there was a Red Wave in Florida
at least what can we learn from what
happened in Florida the women of the
view try to explain what qualifies as
okay free speech in our daily
cancellation a New York Times writer
accuses Jennifer Lopez of feminist
heresy for taking her husband's last
name how dare she all of that and more
today on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
Wade has been overturned and this battle
is now finally leaving DC and going to
the Grassroots no group in America is
better positioned than 40 Days for life
to deal with that with about 1 million
volunteers and one thousand cities 40
Days for life holds peaceful vigils
outside abortion facilities they have a
larger presence in blue states with
California being their largest state
some former abortion facility directors
say that these vigils can cause the
abortion no-show rate to go as high as
75 percent which is detrimental to their
abortion business these law-abiding
vigils have closed many abortion
businesses in America nearly half of
those closed abortion facilities were in
Liberal cities where abortion remains
legal including closures in San
Francisco Chicago and Seattle 40 Days
for life is effectively changing hearts
and Minds in the Grassroots to end
abortion check out their locations their
podcasts and their free magazine at 40
daysforlife.com and you know it's more
important than ever especially now after
the election uh what we find is that uh
the the fight for life
has entered a new phase a critical phase
it's all the more reason to get more
information on the 40 Days for life at
40daysforlife.com
after our marathon election coverage
last night I emerged from the studio and
looked up to see the promised red moon
or I was hoping to see it but I couldn't
see anything because it was overcast uh
it was I think a perfect symbol the red
moon blotted out by clouds and fog just
as the Red Wave lost Steam and became in
the end at most a red Ripple a small red
Splash maybe in the shallow end of the
pool as I speak right now we still don't
know uh we don't have the final results
control of Congress remains up for grabs
Republicans are inching closer towards
the 218 seats in the House needed to
take control but the Senate sits at a
48-48 split right now while the results
in four states are still pending once
again it may all come down to a runoff
election in Georgia as at this moment
Raphael Warnock leads Herschel Walker by
40 000 votes or so
now Republicans had decisive victories
in some races and in some states Stacey
Abrams lost convincingly to Brian Kemp
though she is of course still the
governor of Georgia this morning beta
O'Rourke once again showed off his skill
as a professional political loser
getting demolished by Greg Abbott and
the Texas governor race and the Ohio
Senate race Rising Republican star JD
Vance knocked out incumbent Tim Ryan in
South Dakota Christy gnome doubled her
Democratic Challenger's vote total in
New York Republicans did manage to flip
a few House Seats and then of course
there's Florida where Ron DeSantis beat
Charlie crisp by 20 points not only
taking the governorship but effectively
flipping the entire State red so Florida
is no longer a swing state it is a red
State and that's something that even the
media had to begrudgingly admit
can we just talk about Florida because
we really haven't haven't had a chance
to to do that I was texting with a
source in Florida political Source uh
who pointed out to me that this will be
the first time since reconstruction that
Florida won't have any Democrats in
Statewide office period
so and desantis's victory
Miami-Dade Florida wants a perennial
swing state it turned blue for Obama
twice then read for Trump twice now it
appears solid red thanks in part to a
huge effort in voter registration on the
Republican side and the powerful Latino
vote leaning further and further red
even the Democratic stronghold of
Miami-Dade County turned red for the
first time in 20 years can I ask you
while we've got you um if there's any
single results or any single Trend
that's evident thus far that surprised
you the most tonight obviously all of us
looking at this stuff and hearing both
sides make their projections you sort of
weigh everything based on what you know
and what you can view yourself but as
somebody who's been inside these kinds
of campaigns what has struck you as
legitimately unpredictable in tonight's
results well first of all the Divergence
between Florida which you know can't
sugarcoat a disaster for the Democrats
disaster for the Democrats indeed in
Florida but the entire election
Nationwide was not in fact the disaster
went the other way in some cases Dr Oz
May now lay claim to the most
humiliating Republican political defeat
in American history losing his Senate
race to a man with brain damage
fetterman an offish ridiculous man child
who lived off of his parents money until
recently and campaigned on releasing
violent criminals from prison and then
suffered a stroke almost entirely
destroying his ability to understand
English or speak it both of which skills
that he uh hadn't quite perfected even
before the stroke
still managed to win he was one of the
weakest candidates ever fielded by a
major political party in the United
States and somehow Republicans managed
to field an even weaker one
so we'll return to that in just a moment
but staying on the depressing side of
things both Gretchen Whitmer in Michigan
and Kathy hokel in New York won their
races now you can say that both races
were uphill battles for republicans and
that would be true you could try to find
a moral victory in the fact that Lee
zeldin the Republican Challenger in New
York made it within Striking Distance in
fact he did better than any Republican
gubernatorial candidate in that state in
years
but there really are no moral victories
in politics there are only victories and
defeats wins and losses and the fact is
that nurse ratchet in Michigan and her
Awkward on to New York both won their
races that's it so no matter what
happens from here it will not be the
Republican blowout that many of us
expected neither will be a resounding
victory for the Democrats the voters
certainly are not giving the Democrats a
mandate they might not even give them
control over Congress
let alone a mandate but they also aren't
delivering a sharp rebuke
so where are we left we're left with an
electorate divided confused uninspired
and here are my takeaways at this point
first as a believer in personal
accountability we cannot ignore the role
of the voter in their own voting
decisions
in fact one might even say that the
voter is 100 responsible for his own
vote which means that voters in New York
and Michigan for example chose feckless
tyrants who locked them down during
covid but refused to lock up violent
criminals to keep their communities safe
they chose moral incoherence and tyranny
in Pennsylvania they chose a vegetable
in many states and in many races they
chose to reward the people who are
actively making their lives worse
exit polls for whatever they're worth
which clearly isn't much did
consistently show that voters are angry
they're dissatisfied with the direction
of the country and yet in so many cases
they chose more of what they're not
satisfied with they think we're on the
wrong path
and they decided that we might as well
keep driving down it
this is the kind of election post-mortem
analysis that nobody really wants to
give because it's unpopular to blame the
voters for their own choices we'd rather
treat voters like children who are not
responsible for their own decisions but
I'm not a fan of infantilizing adults in
that way and so I must point out however
unpopular it might be that there is a
sickness in the minds and Souls of many
people in this country it compels them
to choose tyranny to choose dysfunction
to choose things that are anathema to
their own well-being
and this election isn't isn't that isn't
you know breaking news from this
election we've known that's the case for
for a long time now and we have to
confront that fact whether we like it or
not and I certainly do not like it
second all of that said
we cannot let the Republicans off the
hook not by a long shot
yes it is it is actually in a literal
sense insane for pennsylvanians to
choose a cucumber to represent them in
the United States Senate
but it's not as though the Republican
alternative was highly appealing I mean
Dr Oz is a snake oil salesman fraud as I
said during the primaries he's a
carpetbagger phony who didn't even live
in the state he wanted to represent
I actually largely agree with
and and there are some conservatives are
making fun of this but I largely agree
with this assessment from Claire
mccaskill on NBC listen
we should lead the conversation of Oz
and fetterman without talking about
authenticity yes John fetterman kind of
oozed authenticity he was who he was he
dressed how he dressed he was
comfortable in his own skin meanwhile we
had crudites and then maybe the biggest
sin of all the Sunday before the
election or Saturday before the election
he makes reference to people Oz does in
Pennsylvania he says go out and find 10
voters before the Steelers game tomorrow
the Steelers
they didn't even play the next day he
didn't even know the Steelers schedule
now that is really political malpractice
State like Pennsylvania
that's basically right I mean John
fetterman's regular guy stick wasn't
nearly as authentic as she claims that
it was but uh he was more authentic than
Oz most importantly fetterman was a
leftist and for the most part he didn't
try to hide it now with a few exceptions
flip-flopping on fracking and all of
that
but he he mostly ran on a platform that
he believed in it was an insane
destructive radically crazy platform but
it was his platform
Oz meanwhile ran on a conservative
platform that he was making up on the
Fly
Oz too is a is a radical leftist I mean
he was Shilling for transiting the kids
10 years ago he was he was ahead of the
Curve
except he decided 15 seconds ago to
pretend to be a conservative
now voters shouldn't want to vote for a
radical leftist but if they do why would
they choose the one pretending to be a
conservative when they have the
authentic article available to them
right but the authentic leftist who
Embraces his leftism
that's what they want that's what
they're going to take
Oz's campaign had no message it had no
point it couldn't justify its own
existence
Oz had nothing to say
he could even explain like why are you
running for Senate again in Pennsylvania
of all places you don't even live here
like what do you why
could never explain that
he was fighting for nothing but his own
political advancement and that was
incredibly obvious to everyone everyone
except Republican primary voters in the
state apparently and Donald Trump who
endorsed Oz
yet this is symptomatic of a much larger
issue with the Republican Party
Nationwide it has no message it has no
point it has no coherent platform it has
no leadership
it has leaders you know Warm Bodies
filling those roles I mean but they're
not actually leading which is why they
should all be fired and sent off into
Exile in disgrace
I mean it's it's it's one thing to
campaign on the fact that Democrats are
bad
and they are and that's easy enough to
point out we know they're bad apparently
even many of their voters know they're
bad
but you also have to be able to explain
number one why they're bad
and why you're better and what exactly
your vision for the country is you need
to have a complete message
but what is the Republican message it's
a day after the election they still
haven't figured it out
third all of that said
there is one place at least where the
Republican party has a message and knows
how to communicate it and as we already
covered that place is floored in fact
Ron DeSantis conveyed that message very
concisely I think during his victory
speech last night uh let's listen to
this
we have embraced Freedom we have
maintained Law and Order we have
protected the rights of parents we have
respected our taxpayers and we reject
woke ideology
we fight the woke in the legislature we
fight the woke in the schools we fight
the woke and the corporations we will
never ever surrender to the woke mob
Florida is where wolf goes to die
now these election results are shaking
out in such a way as to guarantee that
both parties learn exactly the wrong
lessons Democrats will decide that uh
losing by less than expected counts as a
historic Paradigm shifting Victory and
they will proceed to double down on
left-wing radicalism
Republicans on the other hand will
likely determine that they lost because
they leaned too heavily into the culture
War they'll decide that they should
simply stick to talking about taxes and
leave it at that because that's what
they learn after every election
but Florida proves both assumptions
wrong you heard it there in your speech
Ron DeSantis ran on and governed on a
commitment to Freedom Law and Order the
rights of parents opposing leftist
indoctrination in education and
rejecting woke ideology wholesale
on that final point he is one of a few
Republicans on the national stage who
made gender ideology especially as it
targets kids into a central campaign
issue and do you know what those few
Republicans all have in common they won
and they won big
Ron DeSantis fights the culture War he
fights it boldly and he fights it not
just with speeches but with law and
policy and he wins he doesn't just win
he flipped deep blue parts of his State
red with his strategy he took entire
Democrat voting blocks away from them he
won the Latino vote
and not by pandering
but with a cultural
family first message
and it turns out that's what Latino
voters are looking for
I mean many of them come live in
multi-generational households they value
family
so they don't need to hear latinx and
they don't want to hear the LGBT they
don't want to hear about that
they want to hear about the rights of
parents protecting kids
that's that's what many Americans want
to hear about
DeSantis is perceived as the governor
most invested in the culture War
and most willing to fight it
and this was the result
that was the result
okay and on top of that he is simply an
effective and competent governor in a
country that has too few of them
so and you need to have both of those
okay because you can't just like talk
about cultural issues and all of that
you also have to govern
he does both
the Common Thread connecting the
underperforming Republicans is that most
of them not all most of them were empty
vessels with no coherent Vision or
message
and despite of what you'll hear in the
coming weeks they mostly shied away from
the cultural issues
or they were too busy you know sucking
up to Donald Trump thinking that that
would bring them over the finish line
and that brings me to my final point
which is that
we can whine and cry about this and
throw up our hands in defeat
you know and that's it
or we can see this as an opportunity
because again neither party has a
mandate
neither party came away with a landslide
Victory on a national scale
the voters as I said at the top are
listless confused apathetic uninspired
they're looking for leadership for a
message
for something
and someone to Rally behind
are we going to give that to them or not
now let's get to our five headlines
do you have a mystery smell in your home
that you just can't get rid of you've
tried candles and cover-up sprays but
nothing seems to work the best-selling
Eden Pure thunderstorm air purifier uses
proven oxy technology that quickly seeks
out and destroys any odor whether it be
from litter boxes trash cans dirty
diapers or cooking smells even if you
don't know where the smell is coming
from the thunderstorm will get rid of it
in minutes unlike candles and cover
sprays the thunderstorm doesn't mask or
cover up bad odors it completely
eliminates them best of all the
thunderstorm doesn't require any
separate purchase of a filter it plugs
directly into the wall so as not to take
up any floor space it's compact design
makes it great for traveling as well
right now you could save 200 on an
eat-in pure thunderstorm three pack for
whole home protection you'll get three
units for under two hundred dollars put
one in your basement
you know your bedroom your kitchen
anywhere that you need fresh clean air
all you got to do is go to eat and pure
deals.com that's edenpuredeals.com use
codemat3 to get three units for under
200 that's eatinpuredeals.com discount
code math3 to save 200 and shipping is
free
all right
um well it wouldn't be
an American election in the Modern Age
without um hiccups you know voting
machine hiccups you know how they always
have those uh hiccups and so this is a
report from Fox News
it says the campaigns for Republican
gubernatorial Kerry Lake U.S Senate
candidate Blake Masters and the RNC are
suing Maricopa County Arizona over
issues with voting tabulation machines
the GOP lawsuit uh saltkey pulls open
until 10 pm in the county uh it also
asks the state court to instruct the
inspector to every polling location that
voters
whom the e-poll book have recorded as
having previously voted selection must
be permitted to complete and cast a
provisional ballot so that was the
lawsuit
and what this comes from is uh as as we
say or as the Maricopa County Board of
supervisor uh Bill Gates told Fox News
there was a hiccup
and the hiccup led to uh 20 of the
voting machines going down just like
that
the GOP lawsuit said that the issues hit
at least 36 percent of all the voting
centers
now the fact that we always have these
kinds of issues
the fact that they are so often in the
same places like Maricopa County is
always a problem
um
like at a certain point it becomes a
conspiracy theory
it's a claim that or to assume that
there's no intentionality behind any of
it that becomes the conspiracy theory
you have these kinds of issues every
single time burst water pipes whatever
like you you just you know it's going to
happen and it does
and it's happened here too
so as I've said many times like first of
all is there cheating in an election
of course they're I mean absolutely
that's just a fact
uh the only question becomes where is it
happening on what on what scale did it
happen
but just to deny it wholesale as
Democrats like to do again that's just
that's the conspiracy theory
because now they don't want to talk
about voter fraud uh for them they they
say they talk about voter suppression
and uh in fact they were up they they
were doing that last night
there were left-wing pundits on there
was one on MSNBC for example blaming
voter suppression and in fact saying
that this doesn't count as a fair and
Equitable election in Georgia because
Stacy Abrams
did win
the thing about voter suppression is
that
you know to use a term I find myself
using a lot recently that is unfalsified
that's an unfalsifiable Theory to say
voter suppression because what you're
claiming is that well there are a whole
bunch of Voters who would have voted
but they didn't
and the reason they didn't is because
the vote was somehow in some really
abstract way suppressed like they were
convinced and it's like some kind of
mind game to not go and vote
so you can always just claim voter
suppression it's unfalsifiable
now on the other hand we talk about
potential issues of voter fraud cheating
rigging that sort of thing you could
point to actual things that are
happening like a voting machine hiccup
for example
and also we can look at what they're
doing in in broad daylight
you know TR uh opening up early voting
turning election day into election month
election two months elections three
months
going out of their way to make the
election less secure
um these are all these are all attempts
to in effect rig the election
and then that's to say nothing of the
media and big Tech as we know they did
Hunter Biden laptop that's the most
infamous example it's certainly not the
only example it's the full it's a it's a
full court press all the time but
especially around elections to get rid
of and suppress anything that might be
inconvenient or embarrassing for
Democrats they did 100 buying laptop but
they do that with everything
and all of these are efforts to
influence and in effect Rigby election
all of that is happening
uh
there's also this a lot of the analysis
this morning focuses on Trump and a lot
of that analysis is like this from CNN
this is a typical
uh
typical article here says former
president Donald Trump's endorsements
for political candidates and close high
profile races have not yet given
Republicans the Swift and sweeping
victories they had anticipated for this
election cycle despite many GOP hopefuls
banking on his support to propel their
campaigns many critical midterm races
have yet to be called as of Wednesday
morning but so far no Republican
endorsed by Trump in a toss-up
gubernatorial U.S Senate or house race
has won
among those toss-up races where Trump
had publicly backed a candidate CN
projects the governor's seats in
Wisconsin and Kansas a senate seat in
Pennsylvania and four House Seats are
going to Democrats the trump-backed
candidate with the highest profile who
pulled out a win was JD Vance in Ohio
who was projected to become the next U.S
senator from Ohio after defeating Tim
Ryan
um Trump has traveled across the country
stumping for Republicans at huge rallies
that mirrored event programs of his past
presidential campaign stops and so on
and so forth now
right not all of Trump's candidates did
poorly
JD JD Vance good example of one who did
well and we say Trump's candidates it's
like they he endorsed them but he didn't
own them and JD Vance in particular now
you're not going to take the credit away
from Trump so that's the thing you can't
you can't give him that's what the media
wants to do is is uh and Trump pointed
this out yesterday
um
and of course it's true that
if the candidate loses
then that's Trump's fault but if it wins
it's not true you know that's Trump
doesn't get any credit for that
so you can't do that
um
JD Vance the the endorsement helps but
JD Vance has also was a really good
candidate and ran a very good campaign
on top of that
so so there's a candidate that won
um and some of the ones who who may or
may not lose were still good choices in
my view I mean I like Blake Masters in
Arizona uh I would have chosen him too
if I was Trump I would have endorsed him
uh and I don't know if he's gonna win or
not at this point it's still I guess
it's it still hasn't been decided
and you also can't blame Trump entirely
for candidates a candidate's loss
obviously
but the fact is that he made some awful
choices principle among them was Oz but
that's not the only one
and these again are these are it's it's
not so it's one thing to come along
during the general election and endorse
the Republican okay and then they're
probably going to lose as well you know
you can't be blamed for that obviously
but Trump actually you know Trump is the
reason most likely that Dr Oz became the
Republican nominee to endorse them in
the primaries
and then that nominee went on to lose to
a vegetable
it's not like this was unforeseeable
okay it's not like this is this is some
sort of uh twist ending that nobody
could have seen coming
many of us were saying all along it
cannot be Dr Oz whatever you think of
the other candidates in the in the GOP
Primary Oz cannot be the guy he's a
fraud he's a phony doesn't even live in
the state nobody's going to take him
seriously the fact that he was on TV
doesn't matter nobody cares about that
no one's impressed with that anymore
and we said that and it was to no avail
so what does this mean does it mean that
uh everything
Trump that every pick Trump makes is is
wrong and no but it does mean it doesn't
have a Midas Touch far from it
um and then there's the bigger point
that Trump sort of
reasserted himself into the election
conversation in the days leading up to
Tuesday
and that doesn't appear to have helped
very much either
the other thing he reminds you look at
Trump now in 2022 you look at him after
after 2020.
and there's been a definite change
because Trump in 2016 this is this is
one thing people missed like yeah he was
a sensation uh yes he was uh you know a
celebrity and and all of that
and he still is all those things
but he also it was a very message driven
campaign in 2016. you knew what the
message was it was a forward-looking
message-driven campaign
and people forget that uh it's not just
a personality cult people got behind
Trump because they believed in his
message
any and he hammered that message home
constantly immigration build the wall
right uh that was that was probably the
the number one thing but also drain the
swamp
dismantle the establishment
now we can talk about how well he
followed through on any of those things
when he was actually president but that
was the message and it was a message
driven campaign
and there's this the media wants to
pretend that
that Trump of 2016 was entirely
personality cult that's all it was yeah
there's some element of that there's an
element of that with every with every
you know politician on national scale
with Trump being at the being at the
level that he is it's it's it's it's a
much much greater element
but even so I was message driven
you look at him now though and and like
what is the message
it's it's what it's there's I'm not even
sure what we talk about the problem with
Republicans not having a message what's
your point what's your message
that includes Trump one of the he's one
of the principal violators here
what's your what's your message
what does all this mean
well it means it needs to be a real
Primary in 2024.
you know if you're a Rhonda Santa
supporter there's no point in
complaining and saying that Trump should
just not run and should endorse DeSantis
it's not going to happen
and if you're a trump supporter there's
also no point in saying well desanta
should stay out of it and just this this
rightfully belongs to Trump
it doesn't rightfully belong to anyone
no one's a king you gotta run you gotta
win
and so now that's what we should be
pushing for
this is this is what we're we're gearing
up for is a 20 a primary for 2024
knock down drag them out it's not just
going to be around to say this is Donald
Trump either by the way there's gonna be
a bunch of them jumping in there
we might as well Embrace that let the
best man win
all right not all bad news uh actually
some very good news here in Tennessee
where our incumbent Governor by the way
Bill Lee won easily uh Bill one this is
the first well
Bill Lee won easily we also have the
legislation which is Bill number one
that is uh just officially been filed uh
the first piece of legislation of the
season
which bans the gender transition of
minors in the State uh we've been
fighting for this and now we have it now
it's here so here's the press release
from majority leaders William Lamberth
and Jack Johnson let me pull it up it
says Tennessee majority leaders William
Lamberth and Jack Johnson today
introduced the protecting children from
gender mutilation act providing the
nation's strongest protections against
the removal of a child's healthy body
parts house bill one Senate bill one
bans medical interference that alters a
child's hormonal balance and procedures
that remove their organs to enable the
minor to identify as a gender different
from their biological sex
so this is not just Banning the surgical
procedures on minors of course it does
ban that but very crucially it also bans
the drugs you know puberty blockers
hormone drugs and all that that's all
bands it creates a private right of
action allowing a minor injured due to a
violation of the law to sue for damages
the legislation also allows courts to
impose an additional twenty five
thousand dollars for each violation the
Republican leaders committed to uh ban
gender disfiguring procedures for minors
after troubling video surface on social
media September reports from daily
wire's Matt Walsh showed a local medical
provider promoting so-called gender
affirming care as a huge Money Maker the
report raises Nationwide awareness and
serious ethical concerns about
procedures performed on minors at
pediatric transgender clinics across the
country
uh and then we've got the bullet points
the the statement goes on for a while
but the bullet points
just to review the protecting children
from gender mutilation act filed today
one creates a private right of action
allowing a minor a parent of a minor
injured as a result of the violation to
sue for damages
uh allows a child to bring a civil cause
of action against a parent if a parent
consented to the violation on the
miner's behalf allows courts to impose a
25 000 penalty per violation requires a
state attorney general to establish a
process for reporting violations of the
law allows the State Attorney General to
bring an action against a health care
provider for knowingly violating the law
within 20 years of the violation
uh within 20 years
that's important too uh and then also
the bill makes exceptions for children
born with chromosomal anomalies or
congenital defects now
um
so there's two key points here
well three I mean the first is that
these procedures are banned that's the
most important thing
the second is the financial compensation
aspect of this which I think is really
important
because there are a lot of people a lot
of minors
that are
being victimized by this stuff but they
have no recourse they have nowhere to go
because the law doesn't allow it the law
doesn't allow them to sue for medical
malpractice because according to law in
these states technically even though
what is happening to them is this
Frankenstein Butchery it's technically
legal and so they can't sue they got so
there's just there's no recourse there's
nowhere to go for for justice nowhere to
go for compensation
not that you can ever be fully
compensated when your body is altered in
this way and disfigured permanently but
there's nowhere for them to go that's
going to change in Tennessee
so they have somewhere to go and they
can sue
I also think it's great that they that
the children they can not only sue the
medical providers who did this to them
but they can also sue their parents if
if their parents were complicit
and uh
I don't know how people are going to
react to that or or take that but as far
as I'm concerned that is
exactly what needs to happen
because in many of these cases not all
but in many of these cases these parents
are the number one villains yeah there's
the doctors okay and they're in it for
the money and it's a big Cash Cow and
all that we know that from the videos
that we posted
but the parents like at least you can so
you've got corrupt money hungry
doctors I get that it's not good it's
evil it's terrible but I sort of
understand the concept that there are
corrupt money hungry people out there
that will do terrible things because
they get paid and you you'll understand
their motivation
um
it's the motivation shared by many evil
people who have done many evil things
over history
but the parents
what's your motivation
to consign your children to this
and I'm being somewhat rhetorical here I
know some of the motivation it's it's a
form of virtue signaling it's a lot of
different things
but they need to be held accountable too
and there's one other point in the way
that this bill was written
but I also want to point out
um which is that
the the bill
makes the gender transition of minors it
makes it a prohibited Medical Practice
okay bans it as a medical practice and
what does that mean it means that well
it means you can't do it it's beer band
if you do it you lose your medical
license
uh along with all these other penalties
that will that that come down as well
but it's not criminalized it hasn't been
made a criminal matter
and I I talked to some legislators about
this and they were explaining to me you
know when they and and they first share
the bill with me and
you know the fact that it's not actually
criminalized of course from because I'm
I'm gung-ho and like I want to take
these doctors put it throw them in
prison for 50 years you know for Life
imprisonments what I would like to do
and what they explained to me and I
thought I found it very compelling
is that
if you don't make it a criminal matter
then you are sidestepping the DA's
because one of the big problems that
Republicans have is you got these woke
often Soros funded DA's that come into
these cities and yeah there are a lot of
things that are crimes but the DA's have
the power to decide what they're going
to enforce and they can just say well
I'm not enforcing that you know it's a
crime and I'm not going to enforce it
you say that it's a crime but I say I'm
not going to enforce it
and then what do you do you're just
you're just uh you're handicapped by
that
you you've put yourself at their Mercy
so this is this is a way of getting
around that problem you're not going to
make yourself you're not going to put
yourself at the mercy of democratic
left-wing DA's relying on them to
enforce this law which they simply just
will not do
I think this is a clever way of getting
around that by saying well it's we're
we're going an entirely different
direction
so of course if you you know you remove
you take away the medical license if you
continue practicing medical without
medicine without medical license that is
a crime and you go to prison for that so
it's in effect it's still even
criminalized uh but then you also have
the Civil penalties and you are
initially stepping around the DA's which
I think is a smart idea
all right
so the women over on The View were um
squawking this week about free speech
and I want to go through
a couple of these clips first of all
here's Whoopi Goldberg announcing
um tragically that she's leaving Twitter
over Twitter and the place is a it's a
mess he's already called back some of
the workforce he fired a few days ago
he's putting his Eight dollar charge for
blue check verification on hold first it
was gonna be twenty dollars now it's
going to be eight dollars he also
suspended Kathy Griffin for
impersonating him on a parody account uh
which has started a free Cappy hashtag
to Trent I mean I'm I'm I I'm getting
off I'm getting off today because I just
feel like you know it's it's so messy
and I I'm tired of now
having had certain kinds of attitudes
blocked and now they're back on and I
just I'm gonna get out and if it settles
down and I feel more comfortable yeah
maybe I'll come back but as of tonight
I'm done with Twitter
of course Mo if you're like me you hear
that and you think uh uh oh you were on
Twitter I didn't even know that like
what are the what are the I I just want
to know in if I can get in their own
head get in their heads which is not
really a place I'd want to be but well
how do you think people are going to
react to this do you think people are
you're making some big dramatic
announcement I'm done you know I might
be back later but I just for now I'm out
of there which by the way when it comes
to dramatic announcements that's uh
that's that's
kind of an anticlimactic way to go about
it
I'm done I mean I might come back later
but I'm done for now I will not be on
Twitter again until at least tomorrow
morning if not a little bit sooner but
at this moment right now I'm not gonna
be I am not using Twitter at this moment
while I'm on TV
what do they expect do they think that
people are gonna
the the people think it's good that Elon
Musk took over Twitter are they gonna
say well never mind I mean if this
scares uh Whoopi Goldberg away I can't
imagine Twitter without Whoopi Goldberg
and then you also see once again just
the total absolute fragility of these
people
she says there are all these people that
were they were I was insulated for them
from them and now and now they're
their ideas are going to be I I'm going
to maybe be exposed to some of their
ideas and opinions and their words
and I can't I
I can't deal with that
she also has some thoughts on the nature
of uh free speech I think this is in
clip six
Communications act which a lot which
basically allows this to happen I think
it's section 230. it allows
um you know protection of social media
platforms well they just say that
they're they're third-party platforms
they're not the ones that are putting it
out there and that can only change by
legislation and if the Republicans rule
the sentence though it's a bit
challenging because if you treat it like
a publication then that means they're
liable for any crazy thing someone else
well it is
they keep saying that it's free speech
and some speech is not all for all
speeches not free speech some speech is
not okay free speech so everybody has to
agree on that but if people keep saying
well you read my free speech it's going
to be a problem but you know what
this is going to be this is our problem
but ain't my problem today
some speech is not okay free speech
that's that's it so that there's been
this debate for centuries really about
about Free Speech what is Free Speech
what counts is Free Speech
and um is Free Speech absolute and
Whoopi Goldberg has I guess settled
settled the debate entirely
she says that you know some speech is
just not okay
and how do we know if it's not okay or
not I guess she'll tell us
meanwhile although this maybe has been a
debate
I've never found the debate all that
interesting because to me now they're
always around the margins they're always
going to be the harder kind of cases but
for the most part you know when you with
like
99.9 of all the speech that goes on
it it's it's really easy to to determine
whether it quote counts as free speech
or whether it ought to count as free
speech or not
okay and the things that shouldn't count
as free speech generally speaking if
you're making direct violent threats
against someone actual threats
and using a pronoun you know like that's
not a threat
disagreeing with you is not a threat
saying something like I'm gonna come to
your house and kill you like saying the
things the trans activists say to me
almost every day
that's a threat that's clearly a threat
so that's not free speech at least it
shouldn't be
um trying to explicitly encourage other
people
to cause harm to someone or to commit a
crime
again that clearly shouldn't count as
free speech
uh defamation
right slander liable any any in any form
of speech written or spoken
where you're lying about someone in
order to cause them harm
not free speech
and those are pretty much all the
exceptions
you might be able to come up with a few
here and there but you you know what the
exceptions are when you see them
it's it's pretty rare when you come
across an actual hard case of trying to
determine oh does that qualify as free
speech or not because again I think 99.9
of it we all know
and most of the speech that goes on on
social media it's uh people might be
vulgar they might be
you know they might be cruel they might
be rude
but they're essentially just expressing
their opinion and if you're expressing
your opinion
that's free speech and that all to be
allowed on social media
ought to be allowed on Twitter if
Twitter is saying I mean if Twitter is
saying that they've got if Elon Musk is
saying is a commitment to free speech if
that's what he's saying that's so he
wants to run his company then that means
that people should be able to simply
just Express their ideas and their
opinions and that's it
and if you don't like what someone says
You can disagree with them you can even
block them there's a lot you can choose
not to read it there are a lot of ways
around it
but to me it's not all that difficult
let people speak let them voice their
opinions
that's it that's all
uh speaking of letting people speak
let's get to the comment section
[Music]
[Applause]
you know while today's coffee often
comes with hints of soy Black Rifle
delivers an entirely different
experience bold strong and delicious
black coffee is the coffee that I choose
to get me through the day Black Rifle
coffee is veteran founded and operated
their mission is to help service members
successfully transition from the
military into entrepreneurship they
provide assistance to Veterans who seek
to launch businesses of their own with
the goal of helping more companies like
Black Rifle become a reality black
rifles committed to hiring 10 000
veterans and they're well on their way
as for the coffee itself Black Rifle is
very selective about where they Source
their coffee beans and very disciplined
when it comes to ensuring the freshness
of every bag so go to Black
riflecoffee.com use promo code walls for
10 off your first order or when you sign
up for a new coffee Club subscription
the subscription gives you free shipping
in all coffee Club orders Early Access
to Club deals and promotions and special
discounts from their partner Brands
that's black riflecoffee.com with promo
code walls for 10 off your first order
or when you sign up to become a coffee
Club member Black Rifle coffee
supporting veterans and America's coffee
cool Papa J magic says Matt is the worst
of all the DW hosts when it comes to
pretending to be excited about the
sponsors
I don't know why I'm always accused of
that but uh my excitement is
deeply sincere
Dakota says
uh after watching the Rogan episode I
think you really planted the seed to get
his mind going in the right direction
well you know that's in in a
conversation like uh like something like
gay marriage that's the
uh
that's what you're looking to do you're
like in to my mind anyway
now it's it's very unlikely it's
unlikely in any debate but especially if
something like gay marriage you know a
really contentious topic like that uh
it's unlikely that the person you're
talking to in the moment
will say you know what you're right I'm
going to change all I I have completely
changed my mind about this fundamental
issue
so what you want to do is plant some
seeds say a few things to give them
thinking and if and you know of course
in the context of a Joe Rogan episode
saying not just talking to Joe Rogan but
to tens of millions of other people
so if you can't even can't plant it
plant the seed in his mind maybe in the
minds of others
um
Amanda says my biggest criticism of
Matt's appearance on uh JRE is that
aliens didn't come up not once I can
tell you that is also my
regret as well uh I I just
it I'm not the one leading the
conversation it's not my interview
um I was I was hoping for a pivot point
but then once we got on the marriage
topic even I could it seemed very
difficult to like how do we get from
here to get to to uh space aliens
invading and UFO sightings and I just
couldn't figure out how to bridge that
Gap
but um if there's ever another
appearance maybe we could talk about it
then
let's see
Sarah says side note why does Matt look
so small at his desk did he get a new
desk a broken chair this is driving me
nuts
Steve says excellent show Matt thanks as
your chair seat seat closer to the floor
lately
met freak says for some reason Matt
looks like he's a little person at a
giant desk
like he shrunk about half a foot or
something
I we had this conversation before he
went on and I'm very upset
buy this because I know that
Sean's in the control room right now
celebrating because I I said I wanted to
put the chair down a little bit so that
I could pull my my chair in and get it
underneath the it just bothers me I
can't get it all the way underneath the
desk and so I put the chair down and
then we had this conversation before on
the air where Sean said that I look you
know I look like a little person at the
desk now I look like a small child a
small I look like the sweet baby gang
look I look like a bearded baby at the
desk because it's too too low to the
ground
and uh I was hoping that the audience
wouldn't notice it or if you did you
wouldn't have you would make comments
about it but I should know better
so
Patrick says finish listening to the
Rogan conversation before listening
today the daily wire article didn't
capture how well you handled yourself in
the discussion on gay marriage Rogan
consistently changed between
hypothetical moral and legal arguments
you stayed constant even started
defining which which argument it was as
it went on
uh the longer it went the better you
look still room for improvement though
for example when when Rogan asked if God
makes gay people I really wanted to you
to ask if God makes kleptomaniacs and if
he does is stealing still wrong
yeah to me the question about whether
people are born gay and that kept coming
up in the conversation
to me it's kind of
irrelevant to the marriage question
right like are people born gay where
does that come from
uh all of that
that's not directly relevant to the
question of how you define marriage
and it's yet another road that takes us
away from the main point that I wanted
to stay focused on and I wanted to
hammer home
um but room for improvement yeah
absolutely there's always room for
improvement look one thing you have to
know about me is that I am not satisfied
with anything
ever you know it's it's any show any
interview I do anything at all I'm gonna
go back it's like a football player
watching game tape and you start put
picking yourself apart that's what you
have to do though I think that's what
you have to do to be successful it may
not be to never be satisfied with
anything and to constantly be picking
yourself apart and looking for
weaknesses and looking for things you
can do better that may not be the key to
you know
always being the happiest the most
satisfied person in life but I do think
it's necessary for success
are you still giving your money to woke
razor companies that hate your values
see masculinity as toxic and think that
you should teach your daughter to shave
her beard well there's a better way
Jeremy's razors are 100 real and 100
woke free the premium matte tungsten
handle has more heft than the left the
Razer head pivots without caving and has
six blades that are sharper than truth
those other razor companies they keep
virtue signaling to the totalitarian
left and using your money to do it but
you don't have to let them when you buy
Jeremy's razors you aren't just making
Jeremy richer you're making the woke
left poorer 75 000 people have already
made the switch visit jeremy'srazors.com
to get 40 off your founder series shave
kit that's Jeremy's razors.com Jeremy's
razors shut up and shave now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation
we turn to the New York Times and a
writer by the name of Jennifer weiner
back in July Miss weiner wrote an
article reflecting on a very important
national issue that Jennifer Lopez had
gotten married to Ben Affleck and taken
his last name I only became aware of
this article because Lopez reacted to it
this week in an interview with Vogue
magazine and as you know I am an Avid
Reader of Vogue magazine before we get
to Lopez's response let's first review
Weiner's piece which is titled why it
matters that JLo is now JF
she writes the second chance romance
leading up to last week's nuptials
between Jennifer Lopez and the actor and
director Ben Affleck was a pandemic gift
that kept on giving for Romantics and
celebrity gossip addicts alike every
chapter of the benefit 2.0 Love Story
gave us something new to chew on the
most recent nugget JLo's decision first
announced in her subscription only on
the JLo newsletter to change her last
name
quote love is a great thing maybe the
best of things and worth waiting for She
Wrote signing off with love Miss
Jennifer Lynn Affleck
true love wins except also oof
wiener writes and just so you know
except also oof will be about as
insightful as this essay gets she
continues
Miss Affleck may be surrendering to the
power of love with this her fourth
marriage but given the cringy history
behind the practice a woman taking her
husband's last name feels to me like a
submission a gesture that doesn't say I
belong with him so much as I belong to
him and at this fraught moment for
feminism in America a woman like the
former Jennifer Lopez deciding to change
her name feels especially dispiriting
sure taking your husband's name might be
a way of saying this is for Keeps but
it's also a gesture inextricably rooted
in Peak patriarchy specifically in 11th
century law of coverture which held that
a married woman was for legal purposes
merged with her husband with no standing
or identity of her own that notion hung
on for centuries and still endures in
various forms around the world
now I will not Shock you to learn as
Weiner reveals later in the article that
she herself has been married multiple
times she explains that uh she didn't
take the last name of her in her words
current and final husband
uh it will also not Shock you to learn
that she references the handmaid's tale
writing quote the idea of taking a
husband's last name always made me
uncomfortable reminding me of the
handmaid's tale and Margaret Atwood's
Gilead the ant The handmaids Who exist
to carry the babies of the elites are
stripped of anything that identifies
them as individuals including their
names
as we know if not for Harry Potter and
the handmaid's tale leftist would not be
able to make any literary references at
all just as if not for Hitler they would
be unable to make any historical
references at all
um but in any case weiner goes on for
several more paragraphs explaining what
Jennifer Lopez should have made a
different decision about her own last
name and why her decisions are somehow
relevant to the public indeed she says
Jennifer Lopez's name is whether she
likes it or not a political issue she
concludes
whether or not to take a spouse's name
is a personal decision
but the personal is political now more
than ever and especially for celebrities
like every Star or every Mortal with an
Instagram account Miss Affleck has
constructed a persona for public
consumption she has used her platform to
tell the tale of the upward trajectory
of a strong independent woman a woman
who has gone from backup dancer to
Global Superstar her brand is intense
competence and hardcore self-sufficiency
in control and loving it as she sings in
Jenny From the Block whoever Jennifer
Affleck is in her private life JLo is a
woman who might love a man but doesn't
need one imagine if in her newsletter
she had said I love my husband right now
though women are under attack and I
won't participate in a tradition that's
historically rooted in women
relinquishing their identities and their
legal standing I'm giving my husband my
heart but I'm keeping my name
or imagine if Ben Affleck had become Ben
Lopez
now admittedly I'm sort of surprised
that he didn't go that direction and I'm
also surprised pleasantly slow so by
Jennifer Lopez's response in Vogue this
week
where she offers a defense of family and
of tradition she says reacting to the
New York Times article what really
people are still going to call me
Jennifer Lopez but my legal name will be
Mrs Affleck because we're joined
together her husband and wife I'm proud
of that I don't think that's a problem
and then when asked about the idea of
Ben Affleck becoming Ben Lopez she says
no it's not traditional it doesn't have
any romance to it it feels like it's a
power move you know what I mean I'm very
much in control of my own life and
Destiny and I feel empowered as a woman
as a person I can understand that people
have their feelings about it and that's
okay too but if you want to know how I
feel about it it just feels romantic it
still carries tradition and romance to
me and maybe I'm just that kind of dirt
girl
well well said and now admittedly
Jennifer Lopez has been married
something like 14 times under most
circumstances you would not consider her
to be an advocate or Defender of the
sanctity of marriage and the beauty and
importance of tradition but on this
issue at least she's correct and Miss
weiner in New York Times is like so many
other left-wing feminists uh frivolous
ridiculous spiteful
despising what is traditional simply
because it is traditional without being
able to articulate any reason beyond
that
so there are three points we made here
first
you'll notice how quickly the let women
make their own decisions facade Falls
away as we see time and time again the
feminists left
they respect and value a woman's choice
provided she makes exactly the choice
that they want her to make
if she makes the personal choice they
prefer then it's good that you know she
made a personal choice and they should
respect their choices if she makes the
personal choice they do not prefer
then the personal is political and they
have every right to attack her for it
that's just the way the game is played
second Lopez is correct that sharing a
last name is about Unity it's about
being joined bonded together
the modern enlightened quote-unquote
marriage is one where nothing is shared
separate finances separate names
Separate Lives
and eventually separate houses and
separate divorce lawyers because the
whole point of marriage the reason it
exists is to bring man and woman
together as one that's its beauty it's
mystery it's reason
if you're determined to maintain an
entirely separate identity from your
spouse
then you're really determined to close
yourself off from the true nature and
the greatest joys of the marital Union
now you could say that a last name is
just a last name what does it matter
but but a name is a symbol and symbols
are deeply important and meaningful to
human beings
the choice to share a name is symbolic
as it as discussed but it symbolizes
unity and fidelity
the choice to not share a name is also
symbolic then and what does that
symbolize well the opposite of unity
infidelity one of my favorite Avett
Brothers song called uh murder in the
city says always remember there was
nothing worth sharing like the love that
let us share our name and that's what
that's what it symbolizes man and wife
share a name because of the love that
bonds them together
third Point finally
um
to to Jennifer Lopez's point
tradition does matter
now it may not always be enough to
defend a tradition merely on the basis
that it is a tradition not all
Traditions should continue indefinitely
just because they're traditions
but Traditions matter they tie you to
your ancestors to your heritage to your
past
our ancestors speak to us through
tradition
Traditions are their voice the Democracy
of the dead as Chesterton said
what this means is that if you're going
to tear down a tradition
or get away from one you better have a
very good reason
we may not continue every tradition but
there needs to be a reason to
discontinue it a compelling reason
but because you know even if at first
you you're doing something and you're
and you're saying well why are we doing
this and
the fact that
generations and generations and and and
and for centuries in Millennia before
you people did that thing
that's that's that's like an indication
that there's something worth doing here
and again it's that's not always going
to mean that you should continue it
but to just reflexively say oh we're not
gonna do this anymore
that's the problem and the left reacts
reflexively to tradition only that
reflex is to reject it
it may not always make sense to defend
Traditions merely on the basis that they
are Traditions but it makes even less
sense to attack them merely on the basis
that they are traditions
in the case of marital names the
tradition is good because as we've
already covered it Fosters unity and a
shared purpose and a shared identity
it's also good
because it is a tradition it became a
tradition because it's good and
meaningful
and the fact that it is a tradition only
makes it all the more good and
meaningful
and that ultimately is why the left
wants to dismantle it because they seek
to dismantle everything that is good and
meaningful especially if it's
traditional
and that is why Jennifer weiner not
Lopez is today canceled
and I'll do it for this portion of the
show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]